[Musique]
hier je prend de la valeur avec l'âge
par des quartiers guillot mon flow est
en feu j'suis plus chaud qu'un tube il
au mont plus fondants grâce écoute nos
histoires
même si pète un câble et pissoir fin des
places voir le spectacle tu vas kiffer
jusqu'à la fin quand à mourir d'une et
spectacle ludique des bons mais j'ai un
petit doute
tu es tellement l'ancien quand tu fus
pas la chicha tu fumes chibout il n'est
pas trop tard pour faire péter le quota
je suis content et froid comme une mère
slota on restent les mêmes mais ça
jusqu'à la fin je suis content avec le
petit robert et le gras font débat au
feu dit qu on fait du rap avec n'importe
quel mot quant à claques en deux minutes
chrono
weezigo libye ont débarqué au feu d'igor
fait du rapt avec le coq est mort en
taclant
en deux minutes guillaume je suis plutôt
calme
je ne fais pas de drame reposer chez wam
je te fais une omelette aux cryptogames
la paix si ma mission mais fais
attention j'ai vite le nict a search
prés salés nidation devenu à la mode
comme le quinoa discret et efficace
comme ainsi nos bijoux balance mais ce
week-end tout droit de konoha et dans le
flip c'est un très très gros colloïdes
il veut s'attaquer à moi pose-toi
irréfléchie n'ont pas tous sur ton corps
après tron d'état de pitesti sont pas
débiles mon équipe tu verras vite
bien que les bons mais punchline te font
l'effet d'un coup dans les pelotons
c'est un appel aux risques à l'appel
j'en ai dit ce que je vole au dessus ce
week-end comme un pet touristes à
l'esprit si on s'approche un peu plus du
soleil
protégé par la bénédiction d'allah elle
débarque
dix corps ont fait du rap avec n'importe
quel mot prend des claques en deux
minutes chrono
on débarque
ouf le dico fait du rap avec n'importe
quel mot quant à claques en deux minutes
chrono
aujourd'hui chaux-de-fonds pour vous
piquer ton bidons des chihuahuas je suis
beau chiba et notre bébé donc tu es
aussi crédits mme kama son culte man
balik oui c'est que des cats a créé stud
touche la normale comme un mec qui font
sur la beauté inutile de faire de la
logopédie lâcherai pas danser clope ai
dit tu t'appelles pas à la
tu peux pas tester qui je veux pas
mourir d'inanition d'inanition mais je
veux tu chies les idées avec mes rêves
j'aime pas trop les hipsters
je préfère ceux qui me disent oh mon tel
sens tel sens ça c'est peut-être pas du
freestyle mais je crois que ça falchuk
[Musique]
quand on débarque
ouf le dit qu il fait du rap avec
n'importe quel monde
quant à claques dans deux minutes chrono
et qui dit on débarque au feu dit qu on
fait du rap avec n'importe quel monde
prend des claques en deux minutes chrono
[Musique]